with the SNP in government the principle
of free education has been
re-established we've extended free
personal care and abolished prescription
charges we put the progressive principle
back into our tax policy and we're
building a social security system with
dignity fairness and respect at it's
very heart we've kept our national
health service in public hands
protecting it from creeping
privatization and we have the best
performing accident and emergency
services anywhere in the United Kingdom
Scotland is a world leader in renewable
energy and in the fight against climate
change we're on a path to becoming a
zero emissions country five years ahead
of the rest of the UK and we're making
our voice and our values here'd in
Europe and on the international stage so
we have made real progress but there is
much still to do as we look to the
future we must build a more prosperous
sustainable economy so that everyone can
get on in life we need to become a
fairer and a more equal society in short
we must continue the mission of building
a better Scotland but make no mistake
right now many of the gains of the last
20 years and the promise of a better
future are under threat
Scotland's vote to remain in the EU has
been ignored the Conservative Party has
ridden roughshod over the Scottish
Parliament for the very first time the
UK government has chosen to legislate on
devolved matters without the consent of
the Holyrood Parliament with so-called
moderate conservatives and Phill
retreats and the hardline breaks at
ultras on the March
that is surely only a taste of what is
too
the Tories number one pledge at this
election is to take Scotland out of the
EU against our will
now I don't that there is anyone in
Scotland who is not heartily sick of the
brexit nightmare but the bodies Johnson
deal does not get brexit done it just
opens the door to the next episode of
the brexit Horror Show his breaks that
deal covers the exit terms not the
future relationship ahead of us would
lie many years of wrangling over the
UK's future economic relationships
justice and security arrangements
Fisheries migration and much more what
we do know is the Tories will take
Scotland out of the customs union and
out of the single market a trading block
that is eight times bigger than the UK
alone that will hit jobs and living
standards heart economic analysis says
that it will cost every person in
Scotland 1600 pounds it will take away
rapes and opportunities and it will put
Scotland at a competitive disadvantage
to Northern Ireland with no say over our
future under the Tory deal England will
have voted to leave and will leave
Wales will have voted to leave and will
leave
Northern Ireland will get a special deal
a great deal according to Boris Johnson
and the footage we've seen today
Scotland with the highest remain vote of
any nation in the UK would be deprived
of all of the aspects that make the deal
great for Northern Ireland and instead
be taken out of the EU against our will
that is undemocratic and it is on fear
but of course that's not even the worst
of it the Tories have set an impossible
deadline to conclude trade negotiations
that means in little over one year's
time there will be a renewed and a very
real
of leaving the EU with no trade deal in
place and you know that's why the brakes
at ultras supports POTUS Johnson they
want an audio breaks it and on the
present course that's exactly what he
will deliver as for labor Jeremy Corbyn
still can't even tell us whether he is
for remain or for leave instead labor
see they will negotiate yet another
breaks a deal but just like the Johnson
deal a Corbin do we take Scotland out of
the EU against our will and for the
Liberal Democrats despite all the talk
maintaining Westminster control over
Scotland even under Boris Johnson is
more important to them than maintaining
Scotland's police in Europe when it
comes down to it the Liberal Democrats
in Scotland are not the party of remain
they're just another party of
Westminster they would rather subject
Scotland to tony breaks it then give
people in Scotland a choice over our
future so West ministers priorities can
be summed up in just three words breaks
it breaks it breaks it a vote for the
SNP in contrast is a vote to escape
brixon a vote for the SNP is a vote to
take Scotland's future out of the hands
of Boris Johnson and a broken
Westminster system a vote for the SNP is
a vote to put Scotland's future firmly
in Scotland's hands the SNP is
unambiguously Scotland's remain party we
want Scotland to remain inside the EU
and we want the UK to remain inside the
EU so just as we have done over the past
three years SNP MPs will work with other
parties to try to stop the UK from being
taken out of the European Union and if
there is a hung parliament after this
election an outcome that could give
Scotland the balance of power
SNP MPs would seek to form a Progressive
Alliance to lock the Tories out of
government our MPs will work with others
to protect Scotland and to advance a
progressive policy agenda across the UK
in particular we will fight tooth and
nail any attempt to expose the National
Health Service to a post
grexit trade deal with Donald Trump that
is why after this election SNP MPs will
bring forward a new law an NHS
Protection bill to explicitly protect
the NHS in all four countries of the UK
from being a bargaining chip in future
trade deals that bill would prevent
private companies from taking legal
action through investment protection or
investor state dispute resolution
mechanisms it would ensure that
confidential discounts for expensive
medicines would not be at rest and it
would stipulate that before any trade
deal could come into force the Scottish
Parliament and the other devolved
legislatures would need to give their
explicit consent no new deal could be
ratified unless the Scottish Parliament
National Assembly for Wales and Northern
Ireland Assembly had agreed that the
deal did not adversely impact their
respective health services that is a
concrete example of how the SNP will use
our influence at Westminster and any
party that Ward's our support will need
to match us and over this campaign the
SNP will set out other priorities for
our MPs in the next parliament not just
for Scotland but for the benefit of the
UK as a whole we will demand a real end
austerity with new investment to support
public services and create opportunities
for our young people and an end to
billion pound bonds to the DUP at the
expense of Scotland and other parts of
the UK powers over migration so that we
can grow our population not see it
as a result of a hostile environment
policy that harms our society and our
economy the immediate devolution of drug
laws to allow us to better tackle the
public health emergency that we face
powers over
employment law so that we can protect
workers rights and increase the living
wage real action on climate change
demanding that the UK goes further and
faster and much is the scale of
Scotland's world leading ambitions an
end to the to child camp they abhor n't
reclose and a name to the inequity of
universal credit which is pushing so
many families into poverty no more
nuclear weapons on the Clyde and the
right of the people of Scotland to
choose our own future
the SNP will always always stand up for
Scotland at Westminster and we will
always stand up for the progressive
values that so many across the UK
cherish but after these last three years
it is impossible to escape the
conclusion that for Scotland Westminster
is utterly broken it is taking Scotland
down the wrong path and it is doing so
against our will our place in Europe the
future of our any chase the kind of
country and society that we want to be
should not be for Westminster to decide
and it should certainly not be for a
Tory government with no mandate in
Scotland to impose upon us at this
election therefore there is a
fundamental question at stake for
Scotland we will decide our future will
it be Boris Johnson or will it be the
people of Scotland my intention is that
the people of Scotland will decide
Scotland's future in an independence
referendum next year
the SNP of course already has a cast
iron mandate for an independence
referendum based on our explicit manner
to pledge for the 2016 Holyrood election
so if the SNP wins this election in
Scotland the question should not be to
me or to the SNP what will you do if
Westminster refuses the question must be
to Boris Johnson and to Westminster what
gives you the right to block the
democratic wishes of the people of
Scotland that is an undemocratic
untenable and ultimately unsustainable
position there can be there will be no
Westminster veto over Scotland's right
to choose our own future and build the
kind of country we want to be the fact
is Scotland is one of the world's
wealthiest countries we have talent and
resources in abundance nations of our
size many of them with many fewer
advantage than Scotland many of them top
the league for national income per head
well-being and happiness with our what
do class universities cutting-edge
industries vast green energy potential
and one of the world's most
highly-skilled populations we should be
entering a golden era for Scotland with
independence our country will thrive at
at this election we have a precious
opportunity to secure the right to
choose that better future so my message
to the people of Scotland at this vital
defining election is this if you are
sick of the chaos that you've seen
played out at Westminster on television
night after night after night vote SNP
to escape brexit if you fear the
prospect of an increasingly extreme
right-wing Tory government under Boris
Johnson vote SNP to deprive him of the
majority he creeps
if you despair at Jeremy Corbyn and his
lack of leadership on brexit vote SNP to
make sure Scotland's voice is heard and
if you believe that decisions about
Scotland are best taken by the people of
Scotland
that our future should be ours to
determine not imposed upon us by the
lights of Boris Johnson vote SNP to put
Scotland's future into Scotland's hands
and then let's go on with the job of
building a better Theatre European
nation for this and for the generations
to come